e
good morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have a a
hearing on a non- gerain amendment to HB
1585 that we'll be talking about um
momentarily and then we'll be going into
executive session later uh but before we
do any of that I'd ask you to please
join me in the of
Allegiance flag the United States of
America and to the rep for it stands one
nation God
indivisible and
jce thank you
everyone okay the um the amendment uh is
on again HB 1585 uh 0
98h and I'd like to recognize
representative Jackie gr who is one of
the co-sponsors of the amendment along
with representative Weber now please
please proceed representative G thank
you so the um 1108 224 2024
118h was the amendment that had been put
together by the I'll call it the
steering committee the group of people
that had were responsible for the um for
actually carrying out this work and um
that was the amendment that I presented
to you at the it was a draft Amendment
and so this 1198 is
the
0908 sorry is the amendment that um we
discussed okay thank you yep um any
questions for representative
gr representative Lon um I I guess I
mostly wanted to say thank you for
coming back for this hearing just so we
can make sure that if there was anybody
who wasn't part of the conversation they
have a chance but wonderful work thank
you thank you it was a very interesting
um study in how to draw a
bill representative
Weber and my understanding Mr chair is
that we now have passed out um
1198 which is where the source of my
confusion was which is repres
representative Merchant and
representative
gr's further effort on this and then
there is one small further tweak that
we're waiting for so I wonder if it
would be appropriate at this point for
representative gr also to talk about the
differences between
0908 and 199
1198 just so that all of the people who
are here who are interested have a
chance to hear those differences and and
weigh in if they choose to do so sure
absolutely thank you so during the um
the last hearing on this bill there had
been concerned about the kind of
medication that AA could administer in
relationship to injectable M injectable
medication and of most concern was
injectable medication that would be
drawn via VIA a a vial so something that
has to be determined and measured by the
administrator of the medication it was
agreed by the commission and by the
committee the at hog committee and all
those involved that indeed that could be
something that is that a call up would
be prevented to do so they would be
allowed to
um for example use medication that is
that is already though the where the
syringes are dose such as EpiPen and um
but things that had to be drawn for a vi
from a vial would not be allowed so the
language that representative uh Merchant
and I had come up with is on page two
line
32 where it says the Adit the criteria
for the administration of non-injectable
medication in the process of
approving and then again um line
35 colon medication administration shall
be limited to non- injectable medication
unless self medication is self-
administered so when we reviewed this
with the with the committee the issue
was that um criteria for the
administration of non- injectable
medications it has to do with the
administration of all medications not
just non- injectable ones because
epipens would be considered injectable
and then Administration shall be limited
to non- injectable medication unless
such medication is self-administered
well the whole purpose of this um bill
is if medication is not
self-administered so we um asked that we
take those two um words out of the
amendment and I'm sorry I keep looking
at my phone because the house Community
Services Community Services is printing
up my the amendment yes just just thank
you Mr chair just for clarification what
what the amendment that is being
prepared does is it simply strikes the
word
noninjectable and self in two places no
no it correct it it on line 32 it takes
out non- injectable okay and in line in
line 36 it takes out self administered
okay I'm sorry thank you very much for
that sure and then just to be sure that
rule making is parallel to statute we
are adding that part to rule making and
just the same exact line is being put in
the rule making which is
um also let me just see where that would
be it is there's a rule making section
that was added to this because we need
rule making and in that Ru making that's
where that Clause is put so that the
rules clarify as well the rules and the
statute duplicate each
other representative U
Shapero is the ru making portion in this
amendment it's in the one that you're
getting the one that I'm waiting for
thank you it's in this
one representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman um when you noted the issue
about it medication shall be limited to
self-administered medication not
withdrawn from a vial that language is
also on line six um and then it's
mirrored in the ru making and the ru
making Authority is lines 30 through 36
on page two of this and my question was
if you were looking to um standardize
that language it sounds like um it
sounds like they still won't be
standardized between the two um
because you sounded like you were
removing self administered from page
line 36 are you removing it from line
six as well yes I am actually in my yes
thank you okay perfect and then the non-
injectable is removed on both both page
30 line 35 and line
32 I don't see self injectable on oh no
non injectable is is is okay on line 35
but we're we're repealing it on line 32
taking it out on line 32 okay thank you
yes other
questions representative Palazo thank
you Mr chair and thank you to for taking
my question uh coming back to to the
intent of this amendment we already have
very complex system with many positions
that require certification and uh it
looks where adding kmer a new position
making system even more complex so can
you briefly talk why you think uh this
uh added complexity is justified by
added
benefits if I understand your question
you're asking you're asking why this
position is um is being request Reed in
line of right because the Assisted
Living fac so in
um in facilities where people are being
cared for there's different levels of
care and assisted living facilities have
the least they they Al obviously have
regulations but they are the least um
regulated of All Care Facilities because
the people there are capable of taking
care of themselves
um is considered a home for them and it
could be that they are there because
they can no longer drive or there are
many reasons why they're there um but
it's not nursing care and so they do not
have nursing staff
necessarily but they do have dedicated
people who are capable of helping them
with Administration with the
administration of medication and this is
a position that's been created for those
individuals um they would have to though
take um a nurse a nurse a medication
class which is similar to the class that
lnas get it's a 40-hour class and and it
was and it's been it would be
administered and put together by the
Board of
Nursing representative Merchant thank
you Mr chair thank you represent gr for
taking my
question the intent behind
self-administered medication was the
fact that when I heard during testimony
they want to be able to use an insulin
pen and insulin pens of
self-administered so that's kind of the
root of the word self- administered
there are things like Auto injectors and
things of that nature that phys a
patient can use to self- administer but
hearing the testimony from the
Residential Care people sometimes the
patient doesn't have the dexterity to do
the self- administration so someone has
to do it on their behalf so that was
where the Genesis of self administ came
from um and I think one of the thing I'm
trying to get to is that not withdrawn
from a vial helps to protect someone
basically at that point in time taking
something out of a vial like in a
hospital if you have insulin it's done
by two people um injectable medications
are problematic if they're not done
correctly that's my concern so again
back the same thing is that if it's in a
auto injector a pendant injector and so
forth those are things
designed to be self- administered but
back what I said before if the patient
can't do it because of dexterity
problems arthritis and so forth it still
allows the person to assist that
patient well by putting unless the
medication first of all we all agree
that any medication taken from a vile
cannot be done by a comma that's
something that is agreed by everyone
in and if you put in self admin unless
if you put in self- administered
medication that means
that the person who's we the reason why
they're they need the comma is that they
can't they can't do it themselves so by
putting that in you're limiting the what
the um comma can do and also know that
this is going through Ru making this is
not going to be the end of the but by
the end of the conversation but by
putting it in here you limit the um
ability to Define what the comma can do
and that's I think that should be
decided for by the Board of Nursing and
the um uh Assisted Living folk and the
Nurses
Association and
that's representative pmer and then
representative
Weber so I just wanted to say why I
think this is a very important bill the
number of times I've been stuck in the
hospital not being able to discharge a
patient because there's no one available
in the assisted living facility to give
medications taking up a bed in the
hospital over the weekend having this
poor person sit in the hospital exposed
to all of us um so I really think this
is a kind of critical um piece in the in
the
puzzle representative Weber and then
representative
Lon so so my question is um and I'm
really very glad that representative
Palmer gave us the broad scope here
because what it sounds like to me that
we're discussing here with the
Amendments is a teeny tiny
piece and if I'm understanding
correctly everybody agrees that um
anything that has to be drawn from a
vial or mixed or anything is completely
out of the question the only thing we
are trying to do is make it clearer or
at least give Ru making Authority yes
sir so that if a patient has a
onetime
premixed ready to go
self-administered
medication already in a container like
an EpiPen or but with whatever they need
in it
that if they do not have the physical
dexterity in their fingers that the
calma would be able to help them with
the administration of a medication that
has no mixing or dosing or determining
it's just there and ready to go and are
we and and that
that the the rules for that would be
done by Ru making where the people who
job it is unlike ours most of us to
administer
medication will have the input as to the
circumstances as to how that happens is
that correct that's correct and well
said Thank you and and I just wanted to
say thank you to everybody who's here
who has worked on this because I know
it's been an incredibly long
slog and um we'll keep working thank you
representative Leon and then
representative pushman um thank you U my
question question is about the this
parsing of the language if we have the
language in your Amendment and then
perhaps if the committee report
expresses some of those specific
concerns about how we craft it would
that give us sort of the direction and
the flexibility in Jael car to make sure
that they're appropriately protective
and to put those that into rules as
opposed to statutes yes I know that as a
member of jail car public comment and um
is all part of the packet that we get
and you can believe I'll be looking for
that representative pushman and then
representative Weber thank you Mr
chairman um can you tell me how this um
Amendment I'm just trying to think how
this is going to work with um say a
patient who has on sliding scale insulin
and they have um a pen that you need to
turn the knob on is is that something
that's going to be permitted through
this certification or not not
necessarily no CU that's a whole
different thing okay you're talking
about a dial pen a dialing pen yeah no
not necessarily I mean that's sort of in
between the drawing up of the vial and
the EpiPen where everything is preloaded
so that may not may or may not be I
don't know okay so this is pretty much
only pre-filled auto injector one time
well that's the one that everybody
agrees on that's correct okay thank you
representative
Weber
and I was just going to ask isn't it
true that if we actually manage to vote
this today and get it to the house floor
and get it through the house it also has
to go through the body that we cannot
mention so if people are concerned that
there is more clarification needed we
have not one but two opportunities one
in the Senate and then the rul making so
what we need to do is to keep it moving
get the ru making authorization which
sounds to me like it's there but if
there are people who are not comfortable
with it we still have another
opportunity to work on it you mention
the body that shall not be
mentioned 30 lashes with a wet
noodle uh representative Paz off uh
thank you Mr chair uh can you help me
with amendments so we have hearing on
specific Amendment but we have two
amendments in front of us and did I
understood correctly that there's yet
another amendment being printed so
what's your preference do you want us to
adopt all three amendments in the order
they were received or can you help me
thank you
well there are the First Amendment um
would be fine to adopt it's up to you
you know 1198 would be fine but that was
the one that doesn't really discuss
injectables uh the Second Amendment 1198
discusses injectables but it's rather
strict and it's not something that um
would give a lot of leeway to the
rulemaking so the Third Amendment which
is the one that has my name and
representative Weber's name on it is the
one that I would prefer you um adopt
but
it's your bill you know I so but I hope
that you will consider the input that I
represent the 26 people put together
this amendment so I'm I'm taking their
position an amendment I'm waiting it's
like watching a baby getting born right
you're thinking is it ever going to come
out Mr chairman yes representative
Merchant are we since we're not going to
exact on this until maybe later could we
then at that point in time move this to
um except wait for the amendment to come
in later not we can't I mean again this
hearing is only on the non-gain
amendment not all of the Amendments uh
so much of what we're talking about is
fine but it's really the focus is on
0908 because that's the non gerain
Amendment did I answer your question by
the way or so basically we have to have
a hearing on the next Amendment no no
okay no this is the only hearing we need
so therefore what I'm trying to because
I don't know how long it's going to take
for ol us to get to us if we could
representative
Weber having
had a hearing required on the non-gain
amendment that some of us don't think
wasn't needed but uh we have two tweaks
um either of which or or both of which
can be introduced our executive session
but we don't have to have another
hearing on those they're they're very
close to what already happened so um and
and it's up to the chair but he may want
to take up bills in certain orders
depending on the people who are in the
room waiting to hear about them
so yes representer
Shapero I have a question of the chair
since this is um this is a hearing that
seems to be somewhere between a hearing
and an executive session with discussion
I'm just wondering if there are other
people who are going to speak at the
hearing and if we should kind of move on
yeah if we if we don't have any more
questions for representative groda um
representative go thank you I just want
to make one more comment I'm
sorry I originally there was no there's
nothing wrong with the First Amendment
with the non gerain amendment that we
are having a hearing on now 1198
we can certainly add rule making and the
other components to it in the other body
and and I would certainly support that
um but as soon as we get that other the
third amendment as soon as we get the
amendment from the one that's from
representative Weber and I I will make
sure that we have it that you all have
it okay but I would encourage the
committee to give the rulle making as
much Authority as possible thank you
thank you okay no one has signed up to
speak on this bill other than a
represent representative gr we do need a
PIN card from you please yes I'll do it
right now thank you I have no other I
have no pink cards does anyone else wish
to testify on this uh on this
amendment I'm seeing
none okay representative W did you have
a comment no okay all right if no one
else wishes to testify on this uh
Amendment I'm going to close the public
hearing and and um we in a couple
minutes we'll be beginning our executive
Ive session thank
you
e
welcome back uh we are now going to open
the executive session on several bills
and in deference to our guests lining
the the walls of our committee room uh
we'll start off with uh hb1 1568 FN uh
representative Lon do you have a motion
um yes Mr chairman I move in study and
after a second I'll speak to it
representative palaza do you have a
second I second representative Leon uh
thank you Mr chairman um this I
recognize that this is a really pressing
problem of unreimbursed care for
Medicaid patients um and I recognize
it's also complex and challenging some
of the things that we probably would
need to address would be whether the
response originated through a 911 call
or some other way so that we can
understand and have an idea on what is a
reasonable one to reimburse as opposed
to somebody coming over for something
quite trivial and wasting your time um
that the patient's consenting to the
evaluation um that there's an agreement
that the person doesn't need to be
transported I think there's a whole lot
of things that need to be addressed and
fortunately for us we're not the only
people who have been looking at this
topic and um it I expect to see a bill
that actually deals with this in a much
more comprehensive way hit our committee
very soon as um that there's uh some
pretty full agreement over that other
body about a much more elegant solution
to this problem and rather than the fact
that we weren't able to really have an
idea of how to approach it and they've
put together something wonderful I think
is a good reason for us to move interim
study on this bill and excitedly look
forward to getting to work once it comes
over to us um it' be senville 409 looks
really good and it's uh 70 out of
Finance after it had passed a Voice vote
in the Senate so this isn't punting the
issue um um I just think it's I think
that they've have a better start and we
should move to that work instead
representative Merchant who was the
second it please um representative Paz
off thank
you uh other representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman I'm I'm very
glad that we all support this in theory
um my position is
that I am not understanding why this
bill which is very simple and in my mind
very
clear um has been infused with a lot of
confusion and difficulty and it's all
complicated I don't think it's
complicated I think the bill does
exactly what's needed and for that
reason I will be opposing an uh interim
study and um hoping to move something
else thank you representative Shapero
thank you um
uh from from what I know about Senate
Bill
409 um I would agree with representative
Leon that that one is maybe more
comprehensive and more um detailed um
and and will give us better guidance
moving forward but at the same time in
principle this this bill 1568 which is
very simple and lets us allows us to
take a stand saying that we support
reimbursement for
um for um Emergency Medical Response
um this is a this is a policy that we
can um endorse here and now and both
bills will end up in finance committee
and um I would I would think that
um I would think that
we understanding that the finances
this bill have not been well vetted um I
think as a policy decision we can agree
to support this and send it ahead to
finance committee and that um let others
deal with the intricacies um so I would
also um not vote for a interim study but
vote for um vote vote in order vote
against interim study in order to make
another motion and support that thank
you other discussion representative Lon
um thank you Mr chairman um I I'm not
really in the business of passing
messaging I try and pass bills that
actually will achieve what we're looking
to do the details were so sparse on this
that this wasn't even a second committee
bill because there was no way to get a
handle on what the cost would be um I
fully support all of our First
Responders I just want to make sure that
instead of just saying um yes we support
you so we'll push this through we'll
look to something that's a very
comprehensive one that we can all get
behind and so there can be some clarity
so that um everything is directed a
little bit closer and we can get this
done sooner rather than later um by
doing that other
discussion I'm seeing none okay the
motion is interim study on HB 1568 I'll
ask the clerk to call the
all representative Leon
yes representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofo yes representative
mlan yes representative Seth King yes
representative Moffet
yes representative Nagel
yes representative POA
yes representative Weber no
representative McKay
no representative
predus representative Canon
no representa nut upam no representative
Shapiro no representative Merchant no
representative long no representative
Palmer no Representative taes no and
represent McDonald yes 10 to
10 okay representative wber I would move
out to
pass okay is there a
second representative par seconds uh
representative Weber do you want to
speak to your
motion I think I already have I don't
think I need to belabor it okay any
discussion on the UT to pass motion on
1568 seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the all if he's
ready representative Leon
no Representative kushman no
representative Bill King no
Representative kofalt no Representative
mlan no representative Seth King
no representative Missour I'm sorry um
Representative mofet
no representative
Nagel Representative pza
no representative Weber yes
representative M yes representative
fedus yes representative Canon yes
representative Nutter
upam representative
Shapiro
yes representative Merchant yes
representative long
yes representative Palmer yes
representative tez yes and
representative McDonald
no 10 to
10 all right that'll go to the house
with no
recommendation um and I know I don't
need to remind either of the authors but
um we need those reports in uh ASAP with
the deadline uh this morning or by early
afternoon uh representative Leon
representative Weber thank you I those
um okay that moving on to the next bill
uh HP
1280 uh relative to informed consent and
patients rights representative McLean do
you have a
motion I thought there was going to be
an amendment no no okay then
um I would move uh o to
pass representative kushman do you have
a second second representative kushman
seconds representative McLean do you
wish to speak to your
motion
yeahman yes uh thank you Mr chair um
so looking at uh at this legislation um
the reason I think I'm going to support
this legislation is because I think what
it does is it is it puts forth a kind of
uh a minimum standard uh for for patient
care and informed consent and I think
that um if you look at the provisions
that are in the legislation um it's a
very low lift so we're very fortunate in
this committee to have a lot of uh
healthc Care Professionals um who are
part of our our our team here and I
think if they ask the question of
themselves is there anything that is
contained in this uh that they would not
want to do um no I think they would all
say yeah this all of the stuff that is
contained in here kind of makes sense
and I said it's it's kind of a minimum
bar so as I said it's it's it's a pretty
low lift so the question for me anyways
when I was considering you know where to
go with this is is it necessary though
to to put it in the statute and I think
my answer to that question is yes
because I think if you look at the way
that healthc care has progressed in the
last 30 years um you're seeing a
development of of a very very broad um
administrative uh infrastructure and I
think that kind of changes uh the way
that that Health Care is delivered now
in contrast to the way it was delivered
30 years ago I I think of myself you
know 30 years ago when I was engaging in
a healthcare profession I had a very
different experience than I did now both
with respect to follow-up care with
respect to the kind of discussions uh
that that I would have um with the
doctors um and you know in contrast with
that um I was down in
Brazil and I had a pnea thorax and so I
had to go in and I had to receive care
in Brazil and the amounted I didn't
speak a word of Portuguese really so
they had the doctor and the doctors
didn't speak Portuguese there were all
kinds of discussions and all through the
process and after the amount of
follow-up care was just incredible and
when I look at a couple years later I
had a hernia surgery here in the United
States there was nowhere near that level
of discussion and and even when I was
asked it just really wasn't available to
me and the same thing I encountered you
know with the follow-up care so I asked
myself the question um
if I look at Brazil's doctors and nurses
and and the doctors that we have now
versus the ones 30 years ago are they
better in Brazil are the doctors from 30
years ago better than they are now no I
don't think so I I think healthc Care
Professionals today are just as
committed as they were in the past uh
they have a sense of mission they have a
sense of person uh purpose and they're
they're patient centered but they have
this administrative infrastructure that
has grown up now in healthcare and what
that administrative infrastructure I
think tries to do is it tries to treat
Health Care as a process and once it
does that it looks for efficiencies and
opportunities to introduce lean and I
know this because you know I'm an
engineer and that's what I would like to
do with my processes but I think it's
very hard to introduce the concept of
lean to a discussion between uh a doctor
and a patient I mean sometimes it's
going to be a f minute discussion
sometimes it's going to be a 30 minute
discussion and when I talk to both
patients and doctors I hear from both
sides um there's some frustrations about
the limitations around that and so again
do you need to have something coming in
from the outside necessarily in the form
a statute and as I was thinking about
that I thought back to the early
environmental movement and I remember
back being a kid growing up going to the
reversing falls and just looking at the
pulp effluent coming down the river um
and all the smog that was in the air and
there needed to be an outside influence
to kind of move that I think maybe the
environmental movement has gone a little
bit in One Direction but the intention
when it when it first started off was we
need to bring in an outside influence to
kind of move things back towards the
center and and I see I see that that's
kind of where this legislation has value
because it does kind of set from the
outside from statute that minimum
threshold that you have to maintain it's
a very low bar um that I don't think
most health care providers would object
to and it's a I think going to be a
valuable tool both for patients and for
Health Care Professionals and so um I
hope everybody will support
it representative kushman did you wish
to speak to do your motion um I don't
really have anything to add to that I
think uh representative McLean um
presented it perfectly thank you thank
you representative U TZ and then
representative
Mel uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative McLean because I think uh
reminding us of the administrative
infrastructure that's been growing and
some frustrations and limitations is
part of what's been happening with
Healthcare and this bill has absolutely
nothing to do with an ability to impact
that um this bill is introduced without
any evidence of the need for it it would
be administratively burdensome it's the
standard practice of care as much of the
physicians in the room have already
explained and the way you improve
Healthcare is not the legislation there
are many many means by which to try to
make things better both um within each
individual uh practice organization or
overall uh you know as a sort of um the
practice of medicine as a whole with
guidance and all that and I think that
if I had Clarity on any evidence that
there was a need for this I might feel
differently but as someone who does
teach quality improvement and um has
worked in you know trying to improve
health for a very long time I I really
am scratching my head about this and um
would definitely be voting against it
representative Nagel and then
representative Lon thank you Mr chairman
um I agree with both of you um if I can
do that we don't understand how you can
do it now I have to explain it I'm not
going to say it without explaining I
mean I superficially I thought that this
bill was a waste of time for the every
reason you just said I mean everything
that's in here we already have to do
there's however we've seen a what we
call Corporation or invasion of the
medical industrial complex into healthc
care where within the next 10 years
we're all going to be employed by a
corporate entity of some sort I see this
bill as a protecting not just the
patient but the doctor from that and I
will share an example with you yesterday
I had nothing better to do in my o time
than to look at inform consent that we
were requiring the patient to sign and
that I had to sign too and um these are
brand new hot off the presses designed
by the uh risk management people with
very little input from the doctors and I
looked at this thing and I said this is
an absolute joke I said I can't sign
this in good faith so what we did was
with every patient I saw all 12 of them
I had to go through it and cross that
out cross that out cross out this
doesn't apply that doesn't apply add
other stuff by the time we got done what
was supposed to be a 20 minute visit
turned into a 45 minute visit and that's
what we're seeing now is risk management
people designing these these things and
that is just totally wrong what we need
to do is go back the clock 30 years and
and and do what we did 30 years ago we
actually explain things to people and
not let people in Risk Management Do It
full for us and I think that this bill
actually protects doctors for the
longest time I tried really hard to come
up with a reason and not vote for it and
I am going to vote for it for that
reason thank you representative Le okay
any other discussion representative
primer
so I I think that I started off with
this same thing which is that it's kind
of redundant since we basically follow
the same things what I'm afraid of is
that instead of corporate medicine
telling us what to do this the state
will tell us what to do which and I
don't who's making the rules here and
who's going to decide I mean so there's
line
um 15 C it and it says the burdens risk
and expected benefits of all options
including foregoing treatment so
now I mean I would sort of argue that if
you have the corporate medicine they're
just going to go there well there's this
law we don't want to get sued and who's
made the list of all of the op of all of
the complications all of the options
that need to be documented for this
procedure so I mean I'd want this before
agreeing to support this I'd want a lot
more clarity on exactly how it's going
to work and I'm I'm sort of figuring
it's going to end up being that my I
mean I work in the darath hitok system
and that there's going to be a new edict
Beyond what we already do with peer
review that's going to you know be yet
another layer of stuff in in getting
consent for anything than we have to do
now and it's going to take 10 more
minutes and the people who are paying me
aren't going to give me any more time to
do it they're going to expect that it
gets done and if it takes if I can't
leave till 8 o'clock at night now
admittedly I don't do a lot of
procedures so it's not as big a burden
for me as it will be for a surgeon but I
I would only support looking at this
further I wouldn't support passing it
today representative Lon uh thank you Mr
chairman I'm really having a hard time
with this discussion so this is directly
from the American Medical Association
from their ethics this is what is
required of doctors today our
administrative rules say that you need
to follow the ethics if it's going to be
burdensome to comply with this if it's
going to be different than what's done
today when our administrative rules say
that you need to follow the medical
ethics guidelines from the AMA then that
proves just how necessary this bill
is representative Parmer
so given that we follow the ethical
guidelines or
consent the problem is that the way
things work these days in the system I
work in is that once you have a new law
the lawyers all get involved in that law
and they make the the steps that you
have to go through to now follow the law
the end result should be the same it
should be that we are explaining to
patients what we're doing what the
complications are what their options are
um I'm not arguing that but what I'm
saying is that putting it into law will
make extra steps it's already hard
enough to recruit Physicians to New
Hampshire as it is and every one of
these little steps um adds to the
administrative burden and you know I I
can sort of see that that it sounds like
I don't want somebody looking over my
shoulder and telling me what to do they
already are I'm on our peerreview
committee at the at the hospital we
already watch very carefully what people
are doing and um and so does the Board
of
Medicine I just think that putting
putting it into a law without for me
without sort of more clarity about how
it's going to work and how we're going
to avoid unintended consequences of
making Physicians lives just more
difficult without actually making things
safer for
patients thank you other
discussion rep representative
mlan representative Merchant had his
hand up first sorry representative
merchin thank you Mr
chair one of the things I looked at is
in the patient Bill of Rights which
deals with residential facilities and
also hospitals deals with most of this
so there could be a question about a
conflict between that Bill of Rights and
this try to create another Bill of
Rights number two when you look
at constraints um in essence if you're
taking care of a patient and you don't
have informed consent there are
standards that are going to have to be
met
you have insurance companies will be
breeding down your neck if you don't
meet those standards called liability
you can get sued um so I think it's
self-governing we don't need to have a
statute to enforce the standards that
are out there whether it be Joint
Commission whether it be AMA um there's
enough in the marketplace now that's
going
to protect the patient from that kind of
activity and to have redundancy in the
statute and when you put in statute it's
very difficult to change so things down
the road and come up we you want to
change things you can't go through Jael
car and Ru making to make the
modifications will allow you back to the
legislative process so for all those
reasons I think the intent has Merit but
I think having something in statute
dealing with this is an Overkill thank
you other discussion representative
Nagel I'm just offering a solution I
mean we're hire in all these quote
position extenders or whatever term we
want to use for nowadays you know when
my son had his surgery done in Colorado
the doctor spent two minutes with us and
he was brilliant I mean my son had a
horrible fracture and the guy did
amazing job but he only spent two
minutes of it with us and 30 seconds of
it was spent telling us how wonderful he
was then you know and in the end he was
so it was great but but his his
physician assistant spent 30 minutes
with us doing this at a substantially
lower cost to both the hospital the
system and us and we got all the care we
needed we got all the questions we
wanted answered and I'm struggling
because at least in my practice they
don't do that and I said well why are we
hiring you that's the point I mean I
don't see that the doctor needs to
necessarily do this you have other
people within your office that can do
that but we've had several bills come
before us where patients are saying
they're not getting this and that's
that's the impetus Behind these bills
coming forward like the circumcision
Bill and you know the other bills there
was another bill in there also
and and I see I'm not I I'm going to get
in trouble saying this but I see this
every day where in that two-minute visit
patients aren't getting this and and
they have the right to get it they're
paying a lot of money now between
incredibly High deductibles incredibly
High co-pays and time away from work and
this and that and the other come see the
doctor and then they don't get this
information and I I I it's a really
troubling thing to me and I don't like
the idea of putting in statute either
but we a stand has to be made that we
got to stop doing that the you know
we're here for you people are paying for
our services they are customer we are a
provider of a service and they have the
right to have that heard and if this is
the only way it's going to get done and
that this momentum in the wrong
direction is needs to be stopped and
fine that's that's why I'm supporting it
I it took me like well I don't know when
you brought the bill up but I mean I
remember one of the lobbyists and I
looked at it say why is this a bad Bill
we couldn't figure out why and um you
know but I came around to the thinking
that it's it's unfortunately needed and
and issues that happened yesterday which
is why I'm kind of like ticked off right
now but issues that came up yesterday in
my practice this finally just said
something's got to get done
representative Lon and then
representative TZ um thank you Mr
chairman um so the patients Bill of
Rights was brought up that is not
binding on providers the patients Bill
of Rights is for the licensing it is for
the facilities so the patients Bill of
Rights doesn't impact what the providers
have to do it does throughout the
contracts and that sort of thing we have
another bill today that I'll be
recommending for inter room study
because we're trying to tell the doctors
what to do within the facilities
language for patients Bill of Rights so
we need to make sure that that any
protections we put in are actually
impacting the group of people who are we
we are attempting to speak to so we
can't speak to Physicians directly
through the patients Bill of Rights and
second I don't know how this is bizarre
world in some places the party you
wouldn't expect to be the free market
one is pushing for it here I feel like
um the you know one party has
traditionally been for The Underdogs and
here we are fighting for The Underdogs I
know I've always been for The Underdogs
but I don't know why we're not putting
patience over systems and I think that
this bill puts patience over systems
representative tez and then
representative
Shapiro
um thank you Mr CH I um I think there's
a few things I think uh representative
Nagel I think you need to have some
conversations with your
co-workers um because as an organization
it sounds like there's some you know
like improvements that could happen
based on your own observations that
you're sharing with all of us here I
would I would add that if we really want
to incentivize improved care there's
many other ways to go about doing that
we could say um we we we have
a a a survey where we assess uh patient
satisfaction with you know the process
overall like being informed
understanding the process of consent you
could incentivize that at at
organization levels and then
organizations would work together to
figure out okay do I add a extender an
educator or do because right now burd
putting the burden on the um provider in
the encounter where as representative
Palmer pointed out you're still going to
be expected to only see the patient in
20 minutes which basically means it's
going to be an even crappier job excuse
me for my uh blunt language if now
there's more administrative burden to
doing what is already happening which as
representative Mel explained it's about
the
conversation and as also representative
Murphy has described it's about the
relationship so you have a relationship
you have a conversation and this is
introducing a lot lot of um
administrative complexity that again the
lawyers the administrative types are
going to it's just going to create a lot
of additional burden that is not
ultimately going to improve patient care
it is going to make everything a lot
harder and I've seen no evidence of
anything where this is
beneficial representative Shapero and
then representative work Mr chairman
could I assert a point of personal
privilege please sure okay I really
resent the characterization that this is
one set of people prioritizing patients
over systems and another set of people
prioritising systems over patients you
may believe that that is the result but
I think that you have attributed motive
to a whole bunch of people in this room
who are very concerned about patience
patient care patient rights and we have
reached a different conclusion and so I
think that the assertion that one set of
people is defending systems and not
patience is completely uncalled for and
I thank you for the P privilege I
apologize I did not mean the offense
that came from that I just need I want
us to make sure that we understand who's
at the root of each of these choices and
and I do understand that what we're
looking at is we're discussing the
results not the
intent representative Shapiro and then
representative Merchant yes I I would
just like to takey back on what
representative Tes said um which is that
informed consent in my mind is really
about a relationship a conversation it's
something that um probably many
providers are not that good at we're not
trained in that well um and it's also
affected dramatically by the um changes
in health care and the speed up and the
productivity demands I think there's
tremendous amount of things that are
broken
in our system and
um you know personally I'm not you know
although it's been broadly categorized
as people are hearing from their
constituents that this is a problem this
is not the problem that I'm hearing
about and I hear about a lot of problems
in medical care um but I think this
is maybe one of those things that's more
of an art than a science that some
Physicians some medical people are very
good at I I don't see this as a solution
to um the problem of people not having
the time or not having the ability to
have um delicate sensitive
conversations um with people about what
their care is going to entail I'm also
concerned specifically
about the
um line 9 through 10 about assessing the
patient ability to understand what we're
talking to them about um which of course
is part of the responsibility of every
provider you don't want to just talk to
people and
um regardless of whether they understand
what you're saying or not um so um any
any provider I think would be have that
in back of mind but I think this
particular language opens providers up
for um lawsuits I mean like how does one
assess that someone fully understood
what you were talking to them about do
they have to get a
um you know in some cases if someone has
dementia do they have to get some a
specialist in in dementia care to figure
out if they understand and I think just
the specific language uh is a concern to
me because
um it kind of creates the expectation
that a provider um in the course of a
short
conversation and let's face it we don't
have time for extremely long
conversations um is going to be able to
fully assess whether someone comprehends
um all aspects of that informed consent
conversation representative
Merchant thank you thank you Mr chair
out of curiosity this bill is written
it's going to apply to Physicians
insurgents but there's no reference to
the same issue with natural paths um Nur
practitioners and dentists um oral
surgeons they also have the same issue
um if you want to talk about it that way
so I think about the narrow scope we're
talking about one type of health care
provider and not talking about other
people that we possibly could have the
same issue with number two when you
start looking at the issue here this is
coming from my own experience I know
some wonderful wonderful surgeons that
technically are phenomenal me I would
trust my life to them anyone's life to
them they're just phenomenal surgeons
but they may not have the best bedside
manner so trying to regulate bedside
Mana which is a sensitivity which is a
lot of what this bill is all about I
think is going the wrong direction um so
therefore what I'm trying to get to is
that we're not being comprehensive we're
taking one type of healthcare provider
and trying to have that informed consent
apply to them only when there other ones
out there could be just as devastating
if not more
so and also looking at and saying is
that if we're talking about trying to
control bedside behavior and
insensitivity interaction with the
patient I think it's more like someone
said an art and the science and we have
to allow for that flexibility and try to
legislate
it uh representative King King thank you
Mr chair um I'm very curious about what
um representative Nel has been talking
about um my question for you is do you
find that
um there because time constraints and
money and issues like that that um that
there's sort of a perverse incentive not
to provide as much um um informed
consent because you know if you were to
really spend the time not necessarily
the doctor but maybe your staff were to
really spend that extra time that you
know you're able to see less patients as
a result which means less income for the
firm and if you know that your
competitors so to speak are cutting
corners on that that they are going to
get a greater market share in the long
run and so um you know this happens a
lot in all sorts of Industries you know
it's like for example we don't let you
know athletes take steroids because if
we do let if we let a few of them take
steroids then the rest in order to
compete with them we're going to have to
take steroids too and so it's sort of
like a race a race towards a really bad
outcome and I'm just wondering if you
think that part of the reason why so
many don't give the informed consent
that they should
is
because they just know that they've got
to keep up with expectations and how
much money they have to make and if they
knew that there was a Level Playing
Field that okay I can spend the time
with the patient that's necessary to get
them informed consent because I know
that you know I'm not going to lose
market share by doing that is that does
that make any sense am I thinking about
this correctly thank you um I I'm going
to probably plead the fifth a little on
this one but I I you know I can speak
for me I can't speak for everybody else
um I've been very fortunate in my career
um I'm in a private practice I can do
what I want nobody's ever told me um
what I have to do um my wife is a nurse
practitioner and um I've seen what
happens when um certain entities take
over practices she's been in and how
things change dramatically um however my
wife's probably the most God wonderful
people I've ever met in my life um my
wife is always stuck to her guns and her
morals and it has cost her jobs because
she takes more time than other people do
and that bothers me a lot um with that
said um you know I I've always included
the informed consent from every visit
from the beginning we start to the the
minute we end so the education goes to
the entire time and I spend a lot of
time with people but I'm like really
lucky I also kind of was on the ground
floor of creating a procedure that
generated an awful lot of Revenue that
paid me an awful lot of money so you
know it's not like you know over 37
years so it's kind of like I'm not any
the right person to ask I can't speak
for other people I don't know why they
do what they do um I think what
representative merchin said some of it's
just personality one of my best friends
right now um when I first arrived he was
one of the most prominent doctors in
state and um he um he had a reputation
for a horrible bedside manner but he
amazing surgeon and um
um you know patients really couldn't
stand talking to the guy so I got to
talk to him a couple months or I don't
know it was like two years ago and he
looked at me and he says Dave you go
since you said crappy I can say this um
um he said I was really a prick wasn't I
and I go yeah yeah you really were and I
said but that's all right because you
use people around you to help convey the
information you weren't doing and and so
I'm I'm going off on a tangent on what
you said but um to answer your question
it's it's up to the individual you do
what you think is right if you bow to
pressure that's you have to live with
that that's all I can say representative
kushman and then representative mlan
thank you Mr chairman um so most of the
concerns here are kind of moot because
this is again already in administrative
rules so any legal concerns that are are
being raised about attorneys are going
to start looking at it and then you know
that where were they because admin
ministrative rules have the force of law
um I mean this is a very simple bill
that supposedly Physicians are already
doing and it's just putting it in
statute so that we have it concrete so
if the AMA changes and says you don't
have to provide informed consent at all
in their ethics which is very unlikely
but it's in statute and it's it's the
standard for our
physicians um you know it it's already
there it's it's clearly workable
there's nothing preventing doctors from
using their power of Delegation to carry
this out there's nothing preventing a
standardized form from from offering
this um required information to the
patient and as long as there's you know
opportunity for feedback and questions I
mean I think it's very simple it's very
straightforward and it's doable and it's
already expected so I'd appreciate um
your support thank you representative
mlan and then representative Leon thank
you Mr chair um as as a lay person but
as a patient um I look at this and I
think this is a pretty light lift I I
look at it and I think that this is
actually just the floor and I I
understand and I respect you know uh and
I kind of agree with representative
Merchant's comments about you know the
fact that this is not you know fully
comprehensive and and and I acknowledge
that but I I don't think we want to let
you know the perfect be the enemy of the
good and you know we can can always come
back in in the future and and add to
this but I think you know in spite of
the the the good work that that
representative tez is talking about
that's being done I think just look at
the evidence around us we are on a
trajectory where things are becoming
more and more and more perfunctory in
spite of all those best efforts and so I
think you know we're at a place where
the the time is here to say we need to
have an outside push and that's what
this provides you know and I'll go back
to the example of the environmental
movement you don't want to go back we I
worked at a coal generation uh facility
back in Canada and we had these
electrostatic precipitators but the cost
of using them was very high well an
outside agency came in and said you're
putting too much stuff up the stack and
these are this is the rule change well
guess what they fired up those esps like
no business there comes a point in time
when you've got 30 years of internally
trying to push it in a Direction but in
anecdotally in my experience as a
patient I'm not seeing it and the
discussions I had with other people
they're not seeing it and if it was
going up and down up and down and
seawing okay maybe but it just seems to
be this so you have to introduce
something from the outside and that's
why I'm saying cuz I'm not a fan of
going the statutory route myself but I
think there has to be an outside impetus
and that is I guess that's what I'm
asking the folks maybe potentially
reconsider thank you very much
representative Lon and then
representative Weber um thank
you and M as well um thank you Mr
chairman in 2009 I broke my leg
skydiving I broke my femur um an
uncomplicated only a femur fracture my
first stop was at a hospital in New
Hampshire where they told me that I
needed to consent for surgery the next
morning they couldn't tell me what
procedure they were going to do they
wouldn't tell me what surgeon it was
going to be and they wouldn't let me
wait until I met the surgeon because
they were going to have to already be
putting me under for the surger surgery
before I had a chance to meet the
surgeon I know a little bit about
orthopedic surgery and so I knew that
depending on what kind of procedure I
had was going to dictate the rest of my
life quite frankly between limb length
differences and everything else I had
enough knowledge to get myself out of
that hospital and have myself filmed for
a procedure for somebody who had
invented one of the intermediary nails
so not everybody gets that opportunity I
Pro I I don't know if I'm the only
person in the state who was told you
need to consent to this even though you
don't know what the procedure is that's
what I was told I was told that I was
going to be denied care for at least a
day if I didn't consent ahead of time
that shouldn't be
happening it shouldn't be happening
and it really should be simple to put
this into statute so that hopefully that
doesn't happen in the
future okay representative wber defers
to representative freedus I'm sorry
representative frus I didn't see a hand
up thank you chairman for here letting
me speak um I'm wondering in this what
is the patient
responsibility I have have had several
procedures done one in which the office
gave me a video to watch and watch the
whole thing when I finished watching
that I thought I don't think I want to
do this there were too many suggestions
of what the results might be or whatever
yesterday I met with a physician's
assistant and I bet I talked to him
about 20 minutes new relationship but
there seemed to be an established
relationship right away so I guess we
need to trust that our relationships are
going to get us the information that we
need and that we have access to
information on our own
so I feel like this
is thank you representative
Weber so my comment was just without
wanting to stifle anybody's debate um I
wonder if we could all consider among
ourselves whether continuing to say what
is basically the same things again and
again is going to result in a change uh
or not or or or whether we should
perhaps proceed to a vote but I also saw
I believe I saw representative McKay's
hand and he has not spoken yet so uh I
certainly I I just call upon your
thought processes it's lovely to debate
each other but if if I thought things
were changing I would not have made the
comment representative McKay would you
like the last
word thank you Mr chairman I'll be very
brief uh I've been on this committee for
a very very long time I've always
opposed any
legislation that that
prescribes practice of any kind licensed
um I was a licensed clinical social
worker I I don't want the
legislature uh telling me if I was still
in practice how to
practice and this I don't see that this
is NE necessary I think of Physicians um
already know what's best for the patient
and are going to tell them what they
need to know and and not what they don't
need to know I've had some recent uh
encounters with my with several doctors
and uh I was complaining to myself that
why aren't they telling me what I need
to know now I know what they didn't tell
me what I needed to know because now I
know it and I can deal with it now I
couldn't have them I I think that
physicians's U uh practice is being
invaded by this kind of legislation and
we've seen it over and over again over
the years and therefore I'm opposed to
it thank
you all right uh representative t as I
enlisted something new I'd like to move
to the vote yeah uh thank you Mr chair a
little bit new I um have spent over 20
years of my life trying to improve
health care quality and access and
making things better um I am a family
doc we very much value and I think there
are some differences by you know
specialty as far as temperament
personality and maybe bedside Manner and
how much time you spend with patients
but in general I think we care
fundamentally about patients um patient
centeredness their autonomy their
ability to make decisions and good docs
currently in like who are trained now
are trained to think of it as we're
there to be almost like a coach right
the decision is yours we provide
information we support you um and even
with that appreciating that this is
current you know should be just the
practice because it's the guidance I I
agree um with the point that was raised
previously that there are some things in
here that for example assessing patients
ability to understand you know we are
all of us if you were all my patients
I'd have you know 30 different
experiences we all have different levels
of Education we have different levels of
experience um 40% of the US population
has low health literacy that includes
everybody not just people who are very
low educated that means the ability to
understand and use the information and
the instructions resulting from the
health encounter Healthcare is
complicated and complex and so like
ideally Physicians take all of that
especially since we're just pointing out
Physicians here they take all of that
into consideration and we're conflating
here what I think is bedside manner
patient education and understanding of
whatever the thing is and then
specifically informed consent which
tends to usually be more about
procedures a surgery a you know fixing
my broken leg and I think that is my
concern because
is it you can't just you know you can't
just standardize everything the same
like Health Care depends on continuity
good healthare depends on continuity on
relationship on building the trust the
understanding the sharing of information
and supporting patients to make their
best decisions their choices not just
telling them limited information and so
again uh I have a lot of concerns about
just in general everything the approach
to
legislating uh what is already uh good
practice as opposed to finding other
ways to incentivize Improvement in
healthare overall thank
you all right I'm seeing your other
discussion and we've had a pretty
thorough one already so I'll ask the
clerk to call the rooll motion is out to
pass on L hb1 1280 representative Lyon
yes representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative copal
yes representative mlan yes represent
representative Seth King
yes representative Moffett yes
representative Nagel
yes representative pelosa yes
representative Weber no representative
McKay no Representative predus
no representative
Canon
no representative Nutter upam
no representative
Shapiro no
representative Merchant
no representative long
no representative Palmer no represent TZ
No and represent McDonald yes 10 to
10 hey is there another
motion representative
pmer I said it before and I I would move
um interim study
because I think there is concern my
concern would be how often is this
happening how much of a problem is it
and if it is a problem then maybe maybe
we need to look at this more but I I
would that's what I would support you're
moving interum study is there a second
representative Nal seconds any
discussion do you want to speak to that
motion further or we all set we've
covered it pretty thoroughly I think all
right motion is interim study on hb1
last CL
call Representative l no Representative
kushman no representative Bill King no
Representative kofalt no Representative
mlan
no representative Seth King no
Representative mopit
no represent of Nel even though I second
it
no
representative POF
no representative Weber
yes representative M K yeah
representative fedus yes representative
Canon yes representative n upam yes
representative
Merchant
yes representative long
yes I missed you sorry representative
Shapiro
yes I'm sorry representative
W yes representative Palmer yes
representative TZ
yes representative McDonald no 10 to 10
okay that'll go to the house with no
recommendation uh
not we on a roll here okay moving on to
hb300 relative to trial patients rights
to try act representative Merchant did
you have a
motion believe there's an amendment I
have an
amendment
for
e
sure we've got a bunch of Senate bills
coming up we won't be
meet this is the last these are the last
house bills yes they all have to be done
today
yeah yeah we we uh because of the
difficulty of these bills we we
continued them as long as we could but
the deadline is now so
representative Merchant did you want to
make a motion about to pass on this or I
do but given the fact it is a relatively
long Amendment um whether to delay
discussion on this amendment to a little
bit later another go to another bill if
we can so people can digest I be helpful
if we have
time all right so we'll uh we'll take up
1300 later on we'll leave it till the
end if that that
works um how about uh hp5 1585
representative Weber did you want to
talk about that
one are you ready for that one actually
I'm going to defer to representative
Merchant on that one um and I know that
he has an amendment on that one as well
but it is a less onerous Amendment and I
would also ask Mr chairman I I noticed
that the prime sponsor of House Bill
1300 is here so I wonder if we could
perhaps take that up after this one so
he doesn't have to sit here all all
okay um I'm we can be flexible on
that so representative Merchant I when
you come
back um and last night the amendment on
1300 was emailed out to people it was it
was sent to the
committee yeah
Gary the 1300 amendment was emailed out
last night just so you know to the
committee
members okay so representative Merchant
did you want to make a motion on the
amendment for 1585 I'll make a motion I
to pass okay and just to clarify this is
uh I know there's a number of amendments
floating around on this it's a it's
Amendment uh
2024 1246 h
H um they went that
way I'll second okay and and
representative L on
seconds okay representative Merchant
would you like to speak to your motion
thank you Mr chair the critical piece
that was changed um it's more for
clarification than anything
else after working with uh
representative grer and other folks um I
think this is a little more clarity to
it if you look at page two on lines 3
through six what I trying to get to now
is that many of the injectables come in
what they call self- administered Auto
injectors pen injectors things to do
with insulin and so forth Etc so the
intent is be sure that we're not drawing
from a vial but the device that's being
utilized is actually filled by the
manufacturer not somebody else so it's a
it's a safeguard it's really trying to
be sure that you're in the residential
care facility you have somebody's being
trained but when you get into injectable
medications my concern is that that's
where a lot of mistakes can happen so to
minimize that possibility by having
something that's
pre-filled um as a self injector you
basically help the patient put to pen to
the body if you will push the button
basically auto injector so what this
bill Amendment does to the bill under 3
through six and also underline 35
through 37 is to clarify that so that's
all it's doing it's just being very
clear we're talking about Auto injectors
and not talking about um something
else representative L did you want to
speak to you a second or uh no I think
we've discussed it pretty well okay
representative um Shapiro and then
representative
TZ I just have a quick question I have
um three amendments from the original
bill or at least they have part of one
and two full ones so are we is the
suggestion to um adopt all three
amendments or two of them or just the
last 46 just the last one okay for
representative we they're all amendments
in the entirety they have little tweaks
and so there's no need to adopt more
than one and
um I will thank you let representative
Merchant go on speaking C representative
T has had a hand up thank you I I just
had a question so I I listened to um the
prior hearing and heard the discussion
about the um why we uh don't want the
colas drawing up their own meds but what
about or are there other instances where
maybe a pharmacist or a a privately
licensed level nurse could be filling a
syringe with the a correct amount of
medicine and leaving it to be
administered by the comma um it's
possible although the way the bills
written in all the Amendments so far if
it's drawn from a vial that's prohibited
so whether the pharmacist does it
whether somebody else does it and gives
it to the calmer um that would in my
opinion not be
permissible I mean I know that's how
it's written but that's why I'm asking
would we want to allow it if if you had
the appropriately credential an
experienced person doing it correctly
but leaving it so the person could
administer it should we allow
that representative Weber did you have
something to add to this or I'll
clarify I I would only comment that this
bill has been the subject of yeah about
six months worth of
meetings and what you are discussing is
something that a level of discomfort was
expressed throughout consistently
throughout those meetings for multiple
multiple parties so while it might be
okay my sincere hope is that this bill
now represents what all of these people
are comfortable with and yes there may
be things in the future that we need to
add but my sincere hope is that members
of this committee would agree on this
amendment which is the best that has
come up yet move things forward
recognizing that there will be more
discussion in a place I cannot mention
but mention anyway and further
discussion under rulemaking which is now
included specifically in this amendment
and and so this gets us further forward
and I I don't want to let the perfect
for one be the enemy of the good for all
I get it thank
you other
discussion representative Shapero I just
want to say quickly that um probably a
year ago representative Weber and myself
got an email or call from our County
Nursing Home administrator suggesting a
bill like this and it it ends up it
didn't even apply to nursing homes but
it's been a long long circuitous journey
and I give a tremendous amount of credit
to all the people who've worked on it
and I think we've come up with something
good and that we can feel really good
about thank you thank you other
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call all motion is ought to
pass on U Amendment 1246 H to HB
1585 representative Lon yes
representative Chrisman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt yes representative
mlan yes representative Seth King yes
representative mopet yes representative
Nagel yes representative poo
yes representative Weber yes
representative K
yes represent fedus yes represent Canon
yes repres pres nut upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes represent long yes represent pmer
yes representative tez yes and represent
McDonald yes 20 to
zero okay do I have another motion
motion not to pass as
amended uh representative Nal seconds uh
any further discussion on this seeing
none the clerk is
ready motion is out to pass as amended
on HP
1585 representative Lon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofo yes representative
mlan yes representive Seth k yes
represent mopet yes represent Nagel
yes represent
pza
yes representative Weber yes
representative K yes representative
predus yes represent Canon yes
representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative long yes representative
Palmer yes representative TZ
yes and represent McDonald yes 20 to
zero and the committee report will be
sent shortly okay thank you and there's
no objection
consent okay uh are we able to go back
to 1300 um I know it's detail but also
again we've got the prime sponsor here
representative merchant do you think we
are
ready I think so okay great just myself
here
so you have an amendment 1223
H geted
here yeah
loost if I may just have a second to
give myself organized sure
sure
n this
one I may sure go ahead thank you Mr
chair so did you want to make a motion
of ought to pass on your Amendment
correct out to pass as at on the
amendment DS 1223 H is there a second
1223 H Ral second represenative Nel
seconds go ahead representative Merchant
thank you Mr
chair this came to us um from
a fellow representative and the intent
of the bill is that there are times in
which a patient may not be able to get
into a clinical trial or be able to
utilize certain things that are out in
the marketplace would be a biologic drug
a device and so forth under
compassionate use so this is really
modeled more after the federal law um to
allow it also to occur within the state
law so it does two things one is it
allows the opportunity for patients with
the advice of the physician to utilize
things that may not be in the normal
course uh Capac use and so forth and
number two given the fact that this is
going into that Arena it provides a
certain level of protection to the
provider so therefore the provider if
they're willing to work with the patient
on this and they're agreeable to it
we're trying to provide some level of
protection to the provider going into
uncharted waters that have been fully
validated through through scientific
studies and evidence and so forth but
there's a intent by the patient who's
been informed that this is a possibility
to help you to give you an example of
something I have a dear friend um who
actually has gone to Japan and has spent
several thousands of dollars because the
treatment that they can get in Japan is
not available here in the United States
that's an example and he's actually
trying to work with people federally to
modify certain things to allow for more
of this to occur so all this spill
fundamentally does is allow that
opportunity for a patient who's been
informed as full consent and also to
provide some level of protection to the
provider from
liability and I want to say thank you to
both representative Lon and
representative Nel who and actually most
of this Co representative Leons I want
to say thank you for a lot of the work
you put into it making this uh possible
to bring forward representative wayon uh
thank you Mr chairman and thank you very
much representative Merchant for all the
hard work you put in it as well and
representative uh Nagel so our our
terminal patient rates try law was
passed in 2016 and that was before the
federal U right to try was passed um
over time it's moved from sort of uh
more the compassionate use to more and
more following along the right to try
pathway and our existing law is in
conflict in some areas with the federal
law any of these manufacturers of drugs
biologics or devices are worried first
about whether or not the FDA is going to
allow them to continue making their
products available so that will always
be the first thing that they look to our
statutes because they were in Conflict
may have been one of the reasons why it
was hard to access this I do know that
um when people that I know that were
trying to place compassionate use they
ended up placing it into offices and
into facilities in Massachusetts as
opposed to in New Hampshire when the
person was able to practice in both I
don't know if it was because of the laws
around the right to try or because those
institutions were just a little bit more
accepting of having these um quite
frankly one of them said the person had
to go um halfway across the country as
well uh so this by standardizing it and
making sure that our terms are
consistent with what is now federal law
is a good way way to provide this access
um it does change it from terminal to
life-threatening disease because when it
was first passed none of this was done
on the federal level and everybody was
trying to move that momentum towards it
the life-threatening disease is a
disease or condition where likelihood of
death is high unless the course of
disease is interrupted or those with
potentially fatal outcomes where the end
point of the clinical trial that they
used to study it was survival so you're
talking about that that's just a a more
elegant way I believe of saying terminal
um and it also points back because we
want to make sure that as we focus on
this um right to try this um this
compassionate use we're also not um
pretty much crowding out expanded use
because the the manufacturers can
provide expanded use as well which is
where the physician U requests access to
investigational drug device or biologic
and that one's done by an Institutional
review board um that otherwise would not
be underneath these statutes because
it's a whole different process and this
also points to the off label use because
if it's available on the market the
doctors are already protected from
licensing uh Penal
simply because it's off label we passed
that two years ago um and I want to
thank the sponsor for bringing this
because it was a harder LIF than any of
us thought but I think this actually is
a really nice solution representative
Merchant and thank you Mr chair
following up on resent Lon um I was
initially opposed to change a word
terminal to lifethreatening
but given the fact that so much has been
developed in the markets if you will
with drug therapy specifically that even
cancer today is turning into a chronic
disease so it's not terminal actually
any disease is terminal ultimately but
it's lifethreatening so therefore you
want to change the word from terminal to
lifethreatening to allow for that
broader interpretation of the law
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman I I just wanted to again thank
the sponsor it was really great that you
brought this is a really important issue
um as of Friday we were in a quandry and
we had basically were going to interim
study and we felt horrible about that
but we felt there were so many problems
with this language and personally every
one of us has a terminal illness it's
called life so I I've really I've really
struggled with that whole I look through
definitions all over the place and I
didn't really like any of them and I
think that was a brilliant way to look
at it as life-threatening as opposed to
that and um representative Lyon
basically put everything we were talking
about on paper and you saved the day and
that was awesome and I think we have a
good bill now representative Weber and
then representative
Palmer thank you Mr chairman and thank
you all for your work on this I too was
one of the ones who came to it
saying um and and this is one where uh
like like the previous Bill a lot of
talking
has uh persuaded me that the guide rail
guard rails that are in this bill and
and the parameters that expressed in it
are um are good ones and that um I'm so
pleased that we're able to come to a
place where I can say yeah we really
ought to be doing this and and and it's
taken me a while to get here but I
appreciate all of those who kept talking
and kept working because it's a much
better place to be
in representative Palmer and then
representative mlan so I last last night
we we were talking about this and I
initially had had significant
reservations and then as we were talking
I remembered the AIDS epidemic and
compassionate use of act and then my
grandfather getting Kadin from France in
the 1950s for a blood clotting disorder
that and I might not have ever gotten to
know him if if it weren't for these sort
of sneaky ways in of getting treatment
so I'm I'm now now I'm now I'm now happy
representative
mlan thank you Mr chair um you know I I
believe in the importance of right to
try but the one question I have and you
probably already covered it but it was a
lot for me to digest is what does this
legislation do for us beyond the federal
legislation and I know there was a lot
was kind of thrown at me just a couple
minutes ago but could you just kind of
convince what what does this do beyond
the federal right to try representative
Merchant and then representative Lon
part of it that as representative Lon
said there was conflict between the
federal so the state law can be more
restrictive than federal law but it can
be more lenient so if we don't remove
some of the restrictions we have in a
state law to allow for more use at the
federal level that's what the Bill's
trying to do is allow for the state law
to be in constant with the federal law
to provide more accessibility because
the way the current law is written it's
more restrictive than the federal law
representative L did you want to add
something to that u i if if
representative mlan has another question
I yeah just just quickly so does this so
now from a restriction level we're at
par so we are so there's no
okay um and and further what this does
is it protects those providers who are
doing this from any adverse adverse
things from the licensing board for
doing this so because they're they're
regulated by the State Licensing Board
we need to make it clear that the State
Licensing Board won't come after them if
they're doing this the appropriate way
um and just some of this other language
it was just confusing and conflicting
and my husband's helped place um
compassionate use of drugs and to have
right to try that sort of thing and the
way that our statute was written was
just really really cumbersome and legal
departments just weren't comfortable
with it so now by by removing those
restrictions we have that but we do need
to have those Protections in place
against the licensing uh penalties so
that's why it's important for us to have
in there well thank you very much for
the answer and and all the good work on
this thank you representative Shapero
thank you Mr chairman I'm in reflecting
about this bill I'm kind of
thinking about all the debates and
conversations we've had about limiting
what people can do over the years in
this committee and so it's really
refreshing to have a bill that's kind of
expanding
um what people can do and um and all of
us have had people close to us who've
been in situations where this might come
in really handy and so um I'm really
glad to support this
bill representative Lon um thank you and
I want to thank representative Shapiro
and everybody who was here two years ago
because we did we expanded access for
FDA approved drugs devices and biologics
through our off label so we had already
done that there and if it wasn't for
representative licki bringing to us this
to us we wouldn't have realized the
conflict in the statute so yes we
sometimes see the rir time of the other
stuff but we do good stuff at this
committee other
discussion I'm seeing none I'll ask the
clle to call the rooll a motion is out
to pass on Amendment 1223 H to HB
1300 representative L yes represent
pushman yes represent Bill King yes
represent propal yes
representative mlan yes representative
Seth King yes representative mofet yes
representative Nagel yes represent pza
yes represent Weber yes representative
McKay yes representative
fedus yes representative Canon yes
representative n upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant yes
representative long yes representative
Palmer
yes represent TZ
yes and represent McDonald yes 20 to
zero and if there is no objection we'll
put that on the consent we have to a the
pass I'll make a motion a the pass one
more all right do I have another motion
motion I to pass as amended okay is
there a second representative Nagel
seconds okay any other
discussion saying
none okay and the clerk is ready we will
um motion will be out to pass as amended
on
hb300 representative Lam yes
representative kushman yes
representative
kofel
yes representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt yes representative
mlan
yes representative Seth King yes
represent Mett yes represent
Nagel represent palosa yes represent
Weber yes representative M yes represent
fedus yes represent Canon yes represent
Nutter upam yes represent Shapiro yes
represent Merchant yes represent
represenative long yes representative
Palmer yes representative tez yes and
representative McDonald yes 20 to
zero now now if no objection no
objection okay and I'll get the report
to the chair great thank you so you have
that one representative Merchant you
have one other one right um yes I have
two I have 1585 right okay next up uh we
ready to discuss 16007
yes and I have an amendment okay Mr
chair uh yes I heard I heard a voice now
representative
ly
absolutely okay thank you and thank you
for introducing it thank you for thank
you for being here thank
you
yeah I know it's confusing because you
it's easy to confuse those two
especially where they I sent an
amendment request with the numbers
transposed do we have one Amendment
representative Merchant or
two one what's that we'll start with
that one just one so 1220 is the only
one well 12 no yeah 1220
242 20h is the one I'm okay bringing to
the committee coming
around um any more copies on that side I
have extra copies if
you
so I'll make a motion on
house amendment to house bill 16007 it
would be Amendment
122h and I make a motion to repres
seconds yes he would you like to speak
to your motion yes I would thank you Mr
chair I had a very long conversation
with represent Celli myself repr majer
um also Seth King we had a call and
based upon that triy to come up with
language that we could sort of thread
the needle and the discussion was how
thick the thread was or how wide the
needle was um but we anyways we found
something to um settle on in further
discussion
I found that there um could be some
other situations so I support the
amendment but I may depending upon the
discussion at the bill level as
amended May ultimately change my mind I
talked to representative Celli about
this but the fundamental thing we're
trying to do I think the intent of it is
that when a child is born and the
parents particular the mother feels that
they don't have the resources or The
Temper whatever the reason they are they
want to have the child taken care of by
somebody else that they have a safe
place to do it historically it's always
been through a handoff warm handoff um
part of it though is trying to protect
and make this is anous as possible and
baby box does that so the parent doesn't
actually have to engage with another
human being which gives up their U
ammity which is concerning um so in
essence with the baby box it does allow
for the child to be placed somewhere
safe in a sort of an incubator that is
monitored 24/7 so the intent of this was
to basically say that if you do as a
parent place the child into the baby box
that you will have a certain level of
immunity um from Criminal prosecution
and part of that is you don't want to
have the mother being torn between do I
give up my child or do I try to face the
possibility of some sort of criminal
prosecution for whatever reason so this
was a way to try to minimize that
tension between the two and say at this
point in time if you're willing to give
up the child then at that point in time
there's a certain level of protection
for you so that's what this amendment
does um
it doesn't make it 100% exclusive I'm
not an attorney I wish I was at times
but
well it it would help a lot of times I
think a lot of things we get into from
the legal ease part of it is
that represent of Weber it's it's a it's
a tough when you're trying to write a
law to understand what the terminology
is a lot of it comes into legal ease if
you will and I'm not really trained in
that Arena so it has put me at
disadvantage but anyways that's what I'm
trying to put forth with the committee I
do ask the committee to support the
amendment I may not support the bill as
amended but I would like the committee
to Le support the amendment
representative Weber and then
representative
Shapiro as one who went to law school
and was told that every word in every
statute was a pearl polished to
Perfection by
legislators uh coming here was a shock
uh but even even before I came to the
legislature I was a fan of people
writing in English that could be
understood by uh people who did not have
law degrees and I'm all for it um I
think with respect to the language of
this amendment it does make the bill
better and I'm going to vote for the
amendment
because uh it it does not address all
the concerns that I
have that arise from the extension of
the period of time to 60 days which is a
long period of time uh if a child is
being abused
neglected um or in in some cases
beaten um I don't want to get us to a
point
where that child is put comos in a baby
box and uh there are no
consequences um
I think all of this is pretty attenuated
logic but um for various reasons that
I'll get to when we get to the
underlying Bill I'm not in favor of the
bill I very much in applaud the intent
but I don't think it's going to do what
people want it to do but I will vote for
this amendment because I think it makes
the language marginally better and then
we can go on from there representative
Shapero okay thank you Mr chairman all
this talk about lawyers
and U and uh polished pearls and so I
still don't understand what this
amendment says
um so um like others have said I have um
questions about the underlying bill as
well um but I really applaud all the
people who worked on trying to parse
this
exclusionary um area of the bill um it's
kind of like a moral dilemma that
there's no good answer to so I I give
people an um representative King for
starting us off on um exploring how to
solve such a difficult dilemma but now
that we have a solution I don't fully
understand it so um if there is somebody
who could tell me does this mean that
um that evidence that evidence was
gathered through this process cannot be
grounds for charges of abuse and
neglect well then it says or criminal
prosecution so what can it be used to
charge someone with representative
Weber well first of all I was never a
criminal attorney I was an elder law
attorney so uh I I think there have been
a number of
misunderstandings first of first of all
it was written in the original bill as
an exclusionary rule you cannot use it
at all
and this has at least moved us in the
direction that it might be used um what
I'm concerned about with the way the
bill is written
now
um I think it's still
it it still means
that a parent who may have been abusive
to a child or over a significant period
of time as long as 2
months uh May Escape prosecution because
it says here as a direct result of
apparent acting in accordance with this
chapter and to me and this is just me
and I'm not giving a legal opinion I'm
giving a plain English opinion um as a
direct result means you wouldn't have
known about this except that somebody
surrendered that child and I think all
of us are very much in favor of allowing
parents to surrender a child if they are
convinced that they are un unable to uh
raise the child we want the child to
have the best opportunity at life but I
also don't think that uh this
language
allows the deterrent effect that I think
we need if in fact I'm I I just see the
one horrendous case coming down the road
and nobody knew about this child nobody
reported this child so it isn't like I
think in this case if if say the
neighbors had already called DCF and
said really concerned about the kid down
the
street and then the child was
surrendered you still have the neighbors
and and them talking about their
concerns cuz that's not a direct result
of the surrender but if nobody had ever
said anything about this particular
child and their fears for this child and
the child
arrived very heavily abused clearly
abused uh clearly voluntarily abused or
or severely neglected either one I think
that this means that that's the end of
the story and I'm I'm not comfortable
with that and and it's one of the
reasons why I'm not comfortable with
going from five days to the 60 days so
but that's not what we're talking about
in the amendment so other people may
have other interpretations because it
doesn't matter how much we polish the
pearls people see them differently um
that's that's mine that's my concern
representative kofalt and then
representative
Lon uh thank you Mr chairman so I I
think
um my my reading of it my interpretation
of the language
actually does fall on the other side of
the the center line I I guess um the way
I read this it it says
that any evidence obtained as a direct
result of a parent dropping off their
child shall not be
grounds and to me that that suggests
that there may still be an investigation
and other grounds may be determined
sufficient
I believe that in the vast majority of
cases where a child is dropped off and
it seems very very clear that there has
been
abuse it is it is likely that an
investigation would ensue if
possible that leaves me concerned that
this is not
sufficiently removing the disincentive
to drop off the child um having said
that I do know that a lot of work went
into this and I know that that legal
council was was closely involved in the
process of of drafting this language so
um I will be voting for the amendment um
but I I guess I just wanted to offer
that alternate interpretation
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman um I I think this really is
about all of those hard cases you have
an infant and the parent strikes them
and they're in the car and what do they
do they go to the hospital maybe that
parent's not going to do that do they do
they kill the child or do they go to a
safe drop off and say I and say I lost
my cool I can't do this I'm giving this
baby up because I just did this and I
can't trust
myself it's a horrible thing to have to
think about but our question is do we
want to make it so that child has a
chance to live because the parents able
to drop them off um at this point I I
fall on the side of giving that
protection because I am more important
in that CH more concerned about that
child and that child's life than I am
about that prosecution because that's
what it comes down to um and I want to
save that life it's there's so many of
these other externalities that I wish we
could control for but if we could
legislate about that or if we could fix
that we wouldn't have to worry about
these situations you know it's it's
really a hard Challenge and I understand
why people fall on both sides of this
but I think it's more important that a
parent can say what have I done and
relinquish the child and save that
child's
life other
discussion saying no other discussion
I'll ask the clerk to call the all a
motion is out to pass on uh amendment
122h to
hb67
representative Lon yes representative
kushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative kopal yes representative
Clan yes representative Seth King yes
representative Moffett yes
representative Nagel yes representative
POF yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus
yes representative Canon yes
representative nut upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative long yes represent
Palmer yes representative tez yes and
represent McDonald yes 20 to
zero okay uh do I have another
motion or you also want to make m
motion B pass is amended I assume
representative coo uh yes I move otpa on
U house bill 16007 with Amendment uh
2024 1228 is there a second second
representative Leon seconds would you
like to speak to your
motion um yeah I I I think I'll keep it
brief because I think we've we've said
it all before this bill is intended to
uh to save lives
um I think there are a number of thorny
issues that that emerge um I don't think
that we can solve all of them but I
think we can take our existing uh our
existing law and move the ball forward
and potentially save more lives in the
process so I urge my colleagues to vote
Yes on this motion representative
Weber and while I have exactly the same
objective which is saving more lives I
truly believe we got it right when we
passed the safe haven law that we passed
um I I feel that having the short period
of time and a warm
handoff is just something I in my gut
feel more comfortable with and I
cannot give
it an intellectual
explanation um but
that's what I feel comfortable with and
and this bill as it is been brought to
us I don't feel comfortable with I'm
concerned about the longer period of
time I'm concerned about the fact that I
don't believe that
anybody who
is truly disorganized and unable to
control their behavior and is truly
desperate
is going to be organized enough to find
the place get to the
place uh and and do all of that and
I I just think we got it right the first
time and so that's why I will be voting
no but I do recognize and applaud the
work the
concern and the effort that goes into
this
because we all want babies to be raised
in safe caring loving environments so
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman um I I recognize the concern
around shortening the time period but we
also need to think about some of the
babies that are born they're a little
medically complex and it takes over a
week for the mom and baby to be
discharged from the hospital with that
if they get home in two or three days
into it they just realize that the the
supports they thought that were going to
have aren't there and they hit that
crisis point you know why are we going
to say that somebody that some people
get to have a few days at home before
they have this opportunity versus other
people who have a longer stay don't have
it you know it's one of those areas it's
challenging because I do agree that two
months does open up a larger window but
honestly that first week doesn't seem to
be with the other the new moms that I've
spoken with that's not really the where
the dip hits when you're going through
that because you're still on the
adrenaline you still have people showing
up to help if you have a support network
but if your support network is fleeting
and they're gone two weeks into it
that's where you may actually be hitting
more of your crisis mode and that's
where it actually becomes a little bit
more important for some to have some of
this access um and and I know that
there's some concern around the boxes
themselves too but just because there's
you know I worked in medical devices
these aren't medical devices so it's not
limited to just any certain approved
design obviously that's one where
anybody who's doing one of these baby
boxes would make sure that what they're
doing meets the intent and the
requirements of it but you know it's not
like we're creating any sort of Monopoly
I mean catch me later at one o'clock I'm
fighting the monopolies I'm fighting uh
fighting against that whole sort of
model so um hopefully you understand
that that I see this an opportunity not
just to have one type of baby box but to
have this as um as an opportunity
because some people are just so
incredibly ashamed to say that they
can't take care of their kids and to
face another human they'd rather not
exist than face another human and say
that they failed their child and do we
really want that parent and that kid in
a situation where they'd rather not
exist than have to admit that they
failed and I think this baby Box gives
gives a way to save those lives and
allow them to to make a better safer
choice and move past it representative
Canon and then representative kofalt
then representative
Merchant um I haven't spoken up a lot
about about this particular bill but I
am a co-sponsor um and I value the life
of a child and um my intent when I was
asked to co-sponsor This was um will it
save the life of one more
child um uh I recognize that there's
some potential problems with um
with the bill as it
stands um but that's a fairly complex
topic is do we do we cover all of the
aspects of it um my gut feel is um that
it would be much better to pass this and
get something put into place and if
there's a problem that maybe we need
that state needs to revisit and iron out
what the problems are with this but if
it saves the life of a child I I think
it's the right thing to do and and I
would vote for it thank you
representative Kofa thank you Mr
chairman so just um as a point of
reference um looking at other states in
New England and the time frame that they
allow Connecticut is uh 30 days Maine is
31 days Massachusetts is s New Hampshire
is seven Rhode Island is 30 days Vermont
is 30 days so um that's just a point of
reference that I think a number number
of others have have deemed that to be a
very reasonable time frame I think U
many of them for the reasons that uh
representative Leon outlined um and you
know it may be that the other body wants
to uh to to cut this back to 30 days but
30 days certainly I think is is
absolutely reasonable and um does have
the potential to save more lives
representative Merchant and then
representative fedus thank you Mr chair
I wanted to uh say thank you to
representative cordelli who's in the
audience um for working and trying to
find a way to thread the
needle sometimes uh is a little more
challenging than others this is one of
those challenging
times I went back and did some research
and one of the things that came out of
the Yale School of Law in
medicine is the issue of restricting it
to a parent particularly to a mother um
was
problematic and what it really comes
down to is that sometimes you have
mothers who live in areas that a rle
they don't have transportation they
don't have the way to get to a baby box
number two you have mothers who probably
don't
have the WHERE forall if you will um to
take advantage of the law and therefore
you have to rely upon somebody else to
bring the child to a baby box or to a
safe haven this law does not allow for
that it only allows for the parent and I
I do understand the other side of the
issue that you could have somebody as a
grandparent that could kidnap the child
if you will um but I think we need to be
sure that if we're really talking about
the child and protecting the child that
we have multiple ways to get the child
to a baby box not limit it only to the
mother or to the
parent the other issue I have is what I
call Gross physical abuse um or gross
neglect which is different than abuse or
neglect um again those terms are back to
the
legal ease uh I think defined when you
talk about gross abuse if you have a
child who's been grossly abused and when
you go from 5 days to 60 days that's a
long time to abuse a child and sometimes
you get to the point where you're at the
end of the rope and you really have a
child that has been abused to a point
where it's
almost non-reversible um you could have
a child with a shaking the child and
that's been shown again with person who
takes a child and shakes them because
they just are so frustrated with the
child is the trauma in the brain is
phenomenal so what I'm trying to be sure
of is that if that is
occurring at that point in time whoever
is doing that we're not protecting it
now the way this is done with the parent
If the parents doing it they get get out
of jail free card if it's somebody else
not the parent which is a good thing
about limiting it to the parent then
they don't so I'm trying to look at this
and saying how do we protect the child
not just to have the child come to a
safe haven but the journey from birth
the safe haven that they don't come to
the safe haven in such a way that they
really are still alive but they're not
going to be able to really live and
that's the what I struggle with that's
the Quant I'm in um so therefore I think
the 60 days is problematic because of
that uh third days would be better the
short of the window I think is better um
but right now we don't have uh language
and they are talking about gross abuse
or gross neglect so therefore I would
not be able to support the bill
representative frus and then
representative Seth King thank you Mr
chair um my thought is about the warm
handoff the fact that you're putting
this baby in a box like mailing a letter
what about the mother is there any
intervention for the mother any
intervention for the future of the child
so I would voting itl that we would drop
the baby in the box thank you
representative Seth King and then
representative Shapero thank you Mr
chair I've already spoken a lot about
this bill the first day we um looked at
it um so I will try not to repeat myself
but
um I did I spoke with a representative
from Cornerstone after that day and um I
came to the conclusion that you know my
original Amendment which was going to
scrap the exclusionary clause Al
together that was also faulty because um
and I understand now that you know if if
we're Prosecuting people for what I
would consider victimless crimes um as a
result of this then what's going to end
up happening is that there will be too
many people that would be afraid to use
the baby boxes it would get a bad WP and
then they wouldn't get used and I
understand that completely um so my my
original amendment of just getting rid
of it was too far um however my original
concerns which was just articulated by
representative Merchant remain which is
the idea of not just you know a poor
parent but somebody who really
intentionally abuses children um and the
idea of protecting that is not something
I can support under any circumstances
still I was hopeful that um this
amendment which I did vote for because I
I do think that um the bill should be
presented as intended by the author and
such um but the the amendment
uh it does not thread the needle um and
it doesn't it doesn't um you know
ideally what it would do is it would let
people so to speak off the hook for you
know drug crimes um but people who
really intentionally abuse children um
they would not be off the hook and and
so I went home as I was driving home the
other day thinking about it I couldn't
quite wrap my head around why um why it
just felt so wrong to me the idea of
letting somebody off the hook um and you
know that we often hear it's better to
have a an alive baby than than a dead
baby and I can understand that
completely however um that's not
actually how we we act in society so for
example if somebody were to kidnap a
child and they had that child for a
couple of months would we would the law
enforcement come out and give a Clarion
call to the entire State and say look if
you just bring back the baby there will
be no prosecution whatsoever would we do
that no we would not do that and you
might be able to say well maybe we
should just let the kidnapper off the
hook because um it's better to have an
alive baby than a dead baby never mind
the fact that who knows what they've
done to that baby in the last couple
months so we don't we don't do that nor
should we and it also was kind of along
the lines of like um you know hostages
we don't negotiate with terrorists
because the moment you do that yes you
might save the life of that one hostage
but then you're going to send that
Clarion call out to every other
opportunist who will now say hey look I
all have to do is kidnap somebody
they'll give me the million dollars and
let me go scotf free therefore let's
start doing that and my concern is is
that when we
let people who abuse children off the
hook we are opening up Pandora's Box to
let all of the wouldbe opportunists take
advantage of this there was an article
in in the news just the other day some
lady was pimping out her newborn child
to sexual predators so this is something
that really does happen and my fear is
that if we put something like this in
the law we're basically saying you can
do whatever you want to a child for 61
days as long as you bring it back no
questions asked and I can't go with that
I think we need to send a strong signal
that if you abuse children we will come
after you we will prosecute you under
the fullest extent of the law zero
tolerance for people who abuse children
period so that's why I can't support
this thank you thank you representative
car thank you Mr chairman so I've gone
from agreeing with representative King's
um feelings about accountability when he
first brought it up so eloquently to um
today agreeing with representative kof's
um statement about the immunity not
going far enough um and so I've I
realize how difficult an issue that is
and I've been all over the map but my
real my concerns at this point with the
bill or other than that which are
um I'm uncomfortable with this um being
written for Safe Haven baby boxes which
are essentially um you know specific
company and um I've talked to
representative cordelli about that and
he suggested that there are other
possibilities to look into which I think
is a good thing so I'm I'm I'm
uncomfortable with it being written for
a particular company I'm really
uncomfortable with the whole idea of
putting children in a box I think the
the the significance of anonymity is
probably a little overblown here and
that um you know things go wrong I mean
we have scientists and computer
scientists who will develop these boxes
in a way to um make them as safe as
possible but nobody expected Co um you
know nobody expected some of the um
you know dramatic um things that have
happened like nuclear meltdowns we just
don't have control over te we technology
doesn't give us the control that we
think it has so I am much more
comfortable with someone handing off a
child to Al live person um I am I I do
think that extending the time to 30 days
or even 60 days is a good idea I think
we should keep in mind that this isn't
the only way that people can come to
terms with not being able to take care
of their child and getting help
including putting their you know
terminating their own parental rights
and
um creating the opportunity for other
parents to take care of this baby um
this law is not the only way that that
happens that happens with people coming
to DCF or coming to the attention of DCF
getting involved with DCF and saying
saying that they you know they're really
not capable of taking care of a child
and child goes into forcer home and is
eventually adopted so we shouldn't think
that this is the only mechanism for
someone
um for someone coming to their senses
that they are not able to be the parent
for a child there are other options as
well so for for all those reasons plus
the fact that when we were trying to
when we were trying to interpret what we
wrote as the in the new
Amendment we all agreed that we weren't
sure what it meant um so I don't I'm not
really comfortable with passing a I'm
not I think this is well intended I
don't think it's ready for us to pass so
I'm going to vote against it
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman um and thank you I wanted to
note that this is not set for any
particular company's uh
boxes if I may Mr chair representative
Merchant I just checked on that because
I was concerned about that too but that
is a patented
name it's a patented name yes
ma'am representative McKay and then
representative kushman thank you Mr
chairman 20 years ago is the first time
I remember this legislation coming
before us uh so it's pretty remarkable
that 20 years later it's still here
which which to me means there is a
tremendous need uh for this kind of
legislation and and it's difficult to
get that uh somebody talked about the
symbolism of a box and it certainly
reminded me of a
coffen and uh we can't
[Music]
be driven Off The Track by being
concerned about those kinds of things uh
I think there's a great need uh uh to uh
in addition to what is available to
protect these children this is the
first opportunity I think we've had
since 20 years ago to do that and
therefore I'm going to vote
yes thank you representative kushman
thank you Mr chairman um well my
suggestion I'm not sure if having the
name even though it is a patented name
we're not using
it to sell a different product or
something like that it's it's it's also
a descriptive
name um and not necessarily used in that
manner but I don't know how th that
those kind of laws work um with us
having this in Statue but my suggestion
is that we if this gets through this
committee and then through the house
that we ask this the other body to maybe
change that name once it gets there Mr
chair representative I respond to
Fishman I I concur what you're saying um
but the certain words that we use like
Kleenex Pica um that are patented names
and therefore if we refer to it that way
we're in essence which is my concern
here as a state we're endorsing a
particular manufacturer of a product and
not allowing the free market to do what
it's supposed to do if somebody else
wants to come back into the market and
compete against
it rep representative kofalt and then
representative Nagel I don't
know okay all right thank you Mr
chairman so so my intent in supporting
this and my understanding of this is
that it is not endorsing the use of one
company's product in particular so to
the extent that that is um you know
helpful to anybody who may want to
interpret this in the future that is my
intention U my understanding is that
there's currently one company that um
that makes these boxes but that there
are private con charitable concerns that
have come up with um designs and are
building these boxes in some other
states so I think that there are I
believe three designs out there one of
which is the is the safe haven box um
referred to here representative Nel and
then representative Lon I guess since I
researched it I wanted to bring it up
but I I I really didn't understand the
60-day thing where that number came from
if there was any scientific evidence I
have a graph with all 650 States and
what their rules are 60 would definitely
be an
outlier uh the mode is 30 um most of the
states are in the 29 to 28 to 31 day
range um one's 360 four days so if you
pick 60 that that's an extreme obviously
North
Dakota um but there's only a handful
that are are over 30 so so I I I I mean
again I don't you guys know process
better than me the Senate can certainly
change that I just don't know how you
feel about that or the other body sorry
representative Leon then representative
Weber uh thank you Mr chairman I think
through all of our discussion in
committee it's been very clear that we
aren't looking to endorse any specific
manufacturer um I think that that's
something that easily we can ask to
change and I think the other body knows
how I feel about the government handing
out relationships with for-profit
companies so I definitely promise that
I'll be going over I'm assuming this
makes it through and and and making that
clear that we never had any intent for
that to be that the specific company and
that perhaps a different name may make
sense um but I don't think that that's a
reason
to I'm not even going to make the pun I
don't think that's a reason to not do
this um I think that that really you
know this isn't a partisan thing we have
people that we have people on both sides
that are very heartfelt about
specifically what they think is best
here but I think that I think that we
should see and try and get this through
because I think that this can save kids
and this will still have further
deliberation even after it leaves us and
even after even if it makes it through
the floor representative Weber and then
representative
McLean thank you Mr chairman and uh um I
thank representative Leon for those
words and I I can count so um I'm hoping
that whoever writes uh what I suspect is
going to be a majority report on this uh
will say specifically that the members
of the committee were pretty unanimous
and that I mean my assumption is that
we're pretty unanimous in not wanting
this to be specific and that will be a
fur
uh representation of the intent behind
the
bill I want to go
back to what we have in statute now and
although it has been a long time since
it's been
Revisited I think we got it right the
first time around and what I am
particularly concerned about is the
issue of the warm
handoff and and the short handoff and I
understand understand that
um I understand the issue of the shame
and the concern about somebody who just
can't bear to actually have another
person see them do this or acknowledge
that they're doing this but I am very
concerned about a couple of things one
is who knows who's dropped this baby off
I mean some of us want more people to be
able to drop a baby off but I'm
concerned about
somebody perhaps good-hearted perhaps
less good-hearted dropping a baby off
and and
uh how does that work the other thing
I'm concerned about is if we have what
is called a warm handoff you have to
hand it the baby to a person there is
also somebody there who can be concerned
for and care
about the parent doing the handing off
and perhaps you know one of one of the
things that's my concern is again I I
think we're all concerned about the same
things I think we come to different
conclusions about how we deal with them
but the parent who is in despair because
they're new at this the supports they
thought they had aren't there life is
currently really awful they're worried
they can't do this
um for some people
the act of talking to a live person may
show them that there are things out
there that will help them and that will
help
them maintain their relationship with
this child if that's what they want to
do and I I I understand that there
reasons on all sides for wanting
different things I just I think that
having the intervention of a live
person is really key for me
and
um that's why I don't like being
disobliging but because I do recognize
the concern that comes out of everybody
on this but that's my sticking point
Thank You representative
mlan yeah thank you Mr chair I mean I've
been back and forth like a pingpong ball
on this thing uh because so many good
points are being raised by both sides
and but for me I think at the end of the
day I think where I'm finally landing on
this is ultimately there's just too many
what ifs I a th% support the intention
of the bill but I guess for me there's
there's so many what if and I really
don't have the clarity in my mind in
terms of how these would play out but I
would almost at this point be leaning
towards expanding it out to the 30 days
because I think there's value in giving
that extra time you know but maintaining
uh the warm handoff but I guess at the
end of the day no matter where you come
up there's just so many wh ifs that I
don't think this is is is ready to go at
this point so I think my conscience is
not going to allow me to to support at
this time okay we've pretty well covered
it uh I'd like to move to a vote unless
somebody has anything radically
new last The Collector call a roll
motion is ought to pass as amended on
hb67 representative L
yes Representative kushman no
representative Bill King yes
representative kofel
yes Representative mlan
no representative Seth King
no representative
Moffett
yes representative Nagel
yes representative pelosof
yes representative Weber no
representative okay
yes represent fedus
no represent Canon
yes represent Nutter
upam represent Shapiro
no represent Merchant
no representative long no represent repr
Palmer no Representative tez no and
representative McDonald
yes 9 to
11 okay not passes amended fails 9 to 11
is there another Mo uh representative
Weber in light of the confusion and The
Angst and and some of the points about
um extending the time and some I I think
there are things that we are all really
quite in agreement about uh I would move
interim study so that we could really
work on this some more and figure out
exactly which components we're agreeing
to and which components uh we continue
to have doubts about so I think it's
worth pursuing I know that the goals are
are truly important so those are my
reasons for intern study I'll second
that okay representative McLean seconds
uh you want to speak to the motion
Beyond which you've said no thank you
okay any other discussion motion is
interim study on
hb67 I'll ask cler to call the r when
he's ready representative
Leon yes representative krishman yes
representative Bill King yes
Representative
kofalt
no representative mlan
yes representative Seth King yes
represent mofet yes representative Nagel
yes representative pelosa yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes representative fedus yes
representative Canon yes representative
Nutter upam yes represent
Shapiro represent Merchant yes
representative long yes representative
Palmer yes representative TZ yes and
represent McDonald yes 19 to
one
okay
consent I object to consent I'm sorry I
object to okay so that'll go on the
regular
calendar okay and representative cofal
you write The Minority Report on that
okay uh and the uh passes amended
report
um okay and finally uh last bill to
consider this morning is HP 1067
representative L do you have a motion um
yes Mr chairman I move inter room study
is there a second second representative
Merchant seconds do you wish to speak to
a motion um yes please um so this bill
seeks to address the problem of women
denied hysterectomies primarily because
the physician believes that she'll want
to have more more children even if she
emphatically says otherwise by not
allowing this as a reason to Desy a
procedure it also requires that a
provider refer somebody seeking
voluntary St sterilization to a willing
enabl provider and lastly there's
protection for patients who changed
their mind even though it was
appropriately documented that they
wanted the sterilization so while this
is a very real and important issue of
inappropriately denied care you know
this is a really big problem to overcome
most importantly because it's in the
patient Bill of Rights the patients Bill
of Rights does not have bearing on the
individual action of Physicians if we
were to say um I had actually drafted
some language for an amendment to say
that the reason if the the patient was
not otherwise contraindicated for the
procedure and if it was simply because
of the number of children or their
providers saying thinking that the
person woman woman wouldn't want more
children even though she says not that
if she is otherwise appropriately
indicated there's not BMI issues there's
not bleeding issues there's nothing else
and that is solely the reason that that
can't be a reason because quite frankly
that's discrimination about the number
of children that you think that somebody
should have um I I had some language
that I thought actually was quite good I
sent it into OS and then I realized
we're in the wrong section of law we are
in the patients Bill of Rights and it's
binding on facilities and it was too
late to do anything we can't have
another hearing because it wouldn't be
Germaine I had another bill where it was
drafted in the wrong section I lost my
bill to interim study because actually
my bill was killed it was ited because
of that but we can't change it now um I
I apologized to the sponsors for not
noticing that it was on in the wrong
section before every time I looked at it
I looked at the words I didn't look at
where it was placed and I'm going to own
that error but that's why I think we
should in room study and try and figure
out how we can prevent that
discrimination because somebody thinks
you should have more kids and separate
that out from what doctors do and
deciding if you are actually a good
candidate for a procedure for medical
reasons so I you know I feel badly to
move in room study but I think that's
our only choice here other discussion
representative
Shapiro yes um I found the I found the
testimony brought by the um Prime
sponsor and the other people who came to
be incredibly compelling and um
heartbreak to tell you the truth and
um so I feel bad about not doing
anything but as well as it maybe being
in the wrong area of
law it's a really um seems like a really
thorny
um question to try to resolve like
how how you demand that uh a surgeon do
surgery that they don't feel comfortable
doing um if it's um do you want a
surgeon to do surgery that they're not
that that they don't want to do um so my
question isn't whether it's it's really
a problem my question is I don't really
understand the best way to solve it um
it's definitely discriminatory in my
mind um but I'm not really sure that the
bill had a workable solution um so I
hope that we can work it and figure
something out in the future
representative Seth King thank you Mr
chair um so I originally had an
amendment that was going to remove the
first two sections because I think quite
frankly there was very little support
for those first two sections in this
committee um but there did seem to be
some support for the third section which
was just basically going to provide
immunity for the doctors that somebody
couldn't later have regrets that they're
going to be sterilized um I didn't
reintroduce it today because I was
convinced by both um uh the vice chair
and the ranking member that it didn't
belong in the in the part that it was
trying to stick it into so I'm I'm going
to support interim study My Hope Is and
I suspect that um the first two parts of
the bill are not going to be supported
and that um maybe they can just kind of
figure out how to protect doctors from
you know frivolous lawsuits and and
allow them the freedom to perform
sterilization without the fear that
somebody's going to have regrets later
on that's that's my hope I think it'll
happen so that's why representative
palazov um I will be voting against the
interim study um and I I agree that uh
the bill is introduced is probably too
broad and um maybe it has some other
issues but uh as was said it's a real
and important issue and as I was told I
I was telling during the hearing I
believe that culture has changed and our
culture does not value fertility as much
as it was in the past and medical
education also does not value fertility
as much as so uh even though we have
some medical professionals who
might uh deny treatment uh uh I think uh
it will quickly go away uh the way uh
culture and education changed uh so I
think it's important to pass something
like that now because it's real an
important issue thank you other
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call a rooll motion is interim
study on House Bill
1067 representative Lan yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt yes representative
McAn yes
representative Seth King yes
representative mofet yes representative
Nagel
no representative POA
no representative Weber
yes representative McKay
no representative fedus
yes representative Canon
yes representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant
yes representative long
yes representative Palmer
yes representative TZ yes and
represented McDonald yes
17-3 and I going consent um is there any
objection to
consent we put that on consent
okay is does everybody know uh does do
all the authors of reports know who they
are do I need to review
it if there's no questions or if you
want to see me after about anything let
me know otherwise um I have nothing else
this morning so uh we have not scheduled
any Senate bills yet uh probably be the
week after next we'll start we'll
start what's that meeting next week no
committee meeting next week does that I
know of anyway and we probably want to
see how many people might be stuck in
the mud with the solar eclipse too
that's the other thing um do we have any
indication as far as next week with
house sessions uh I believe we're
meeting next Thursday I think the
speaker said every Thursday in
marchs but we meeting in the house
session for Wednesday and Thursday no
just Thursday
Thursday okay thank you every one uh we
are
adjourned